today's topic we got another jubilee
video
and i'm in it for love i'm in it for
love i'm in it for love i'm in it for
love i'm in it for love here's the catch
some of them are lying and trying to win
a cash prize can our bachelorette
eliminate the gold diggers and find a
true match or will they just get played
i know this voice
is this elizabeth
who's elizabeth
remember that thick girl with the
glasses of black girl who had to pretend
she was white
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
shout out to her
yeah i can hear the thickness through
the voice this is love or money
welcome to love or money are you guys
excited
yeah yeah yeah
be like yo abba how did you hear that
voice how did you how did you know bro
you know when it comes to ladies let me
tell y'all it's just about the little
things you understand can you remember
the tiny details they appreciate that
all right enough enough of my fuckboy
tutorial
yeah thrilled hannah these are your
potential matches do you see your future
boyfriend in here
possibly
elizabeth's not thick she's fit
all right well
no
now that you met your bachelorette
you're gonna decide if you're in it for
love or money underneath your chair you
have an envelope and a marker and you're
gonna write if you're in it for love or
money and just so you know once you put
love i appreciate the fact that they got
to choose this after they looked
that's crazy right
they took one look at it here comes the
money
you're gonna write if you're in it for
love or money and just so you know once
you put love or money you are locked in
for the whole show and you cannot change
your answer
hey i'm darren i like your socks i'm 23
and i work at a tech company darren
he's in it for love
he's definitely in it for love
daryn will take what he can get i
appreciate them i love your socks what
they're blue too calm down yeah yeah
yeah it did darren you're gonna get
eliminated but i know i know you're in
it for the right reason so i appreciate
you man my name is emmanuel i'm 22. i
also like your socks and i work as a
physicist at stanford remotely hi i'm
sebastian i'm 21 and i'm looking for a
marketing internship right now and i
also like your socks
oh my god all the guys like oh you're
there for love we're competing on socks
oh that's the cold [ __ ] okay sucks it
is okay
i reloaded
i like your socks too
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say these last
two are in it for money i wanna like see
height differences okay wait i just want
to like come up to you guys
oh this is
okay
again okay
what are you guys giggling about
this is so normal
what are you giggling about mitch you've
been giggling since you've been on this
set
you didn't see this girl turn into a
[ __ ] japanese school girl
[Laughter]
you know what's funny once i went to
this anime convention because i had to
do a stand-up set so i went there while
i was at the end right here
yeah
in case you guys ever wonder if i'm
lying about these stories it's right
here okay
i don't make any stories okay okay see
that that proof came out of nowhere so
i'm out of talking right and this young
wait can i feel everyone's arms
can i do that
as you wish
you please man
oh my god stop stop stop stop
stop
stop was this inappropriate
i'm gonna line a bunch of [ __ ] and be
like yeah let me see your titty meat
size yeah mm-hmm
cool now let me touch them
no can't do that bruh why not go ahead
bruh bruh why is that wrong if i have to
explain this [ __ ] to you yeah let me let
me feel your muscle let me feel your
legs
let me feel all that bubble yeah turn
around and see your butt yeah oh yeah
you got some good good glutes
good goose
wait
okay
oh my god you guys
stop it
um this is really fun
that's all i hear
[Applause]
bro
[Laughter]
oh that's all i [ __ ] hear though
that's what she did
that's what she did you played that
video about to turn to my right and make
sure you weren't a young white lady just
just you know i was like just for just
for the edit just for the edit
put a dark put it dark all dark and then
just play what she's doing right there
oh my god you guys
stop it
follow me guys
[Music]
the [ __ ] is this i like all their
personalities so far they seem great
they made me feel really comfortable
what did you say
i like all their personalities so
what the far did you say
what the
[ __ ]
you know this is the question based on
what
you know what this is the equivalent of
it's the equivalent of a guy looking at
girl's tits and be like nice
personalities
she's with personality i hope i made
them feel comfortable even though it was
kind of weird i'm like oh no i shouldn't
have asked to touch their arms
i went down and they were like really
relaxed and then i went to touch and
they went
welcome back guys did you guys have fun
meeting hannah a lot of a lot well two
of you are about to be eliminated you
know part of me hopes and wishes that
the asian guy is there for the money
because he's doing such a great job
acting and he's so enthusiastic that if
he was there for
for the money it would just be the
greatest plot twist you know what i'm
saying yeah you know
good platform yeah
it's like finding out like jim gordon is
actually the joker
you know what i'm saying
i want that please
hannah
logan i'm so sorry yeah that was fun
yeah and i was fine like [ __ ] i'm
getting like a blue job later or
whatever and you oh
okay
this is round two hannah's gonna get a
little deeper with her potential matches
and she has five minutes to speed date
all of them what what are you the best
at
what are you planning second dates but i
guess you'd have to find out after yeah
oh sh wait what scares you what scares
me yeah probably
living in a world without family like
being the only one left
oh my god all about yourself um
something so weird about me is um i was
always afraid of people in like mascot
costumes
like chuck e cheese like stuff like that
[Laughter]
you want to appreciate the contrast
between the two what are you terrified
of just losing my whole family oh well
i'm afraid of chuck e
[Laughter]
what's the cheese traumatic thing ever
well i lost both my parents in a car
accident what about you chuck e cheese
oh my god
man we're never going to finish this are
you ready to eliminate one
guy yes are you nervous yeah oh i feel
bad unfortunately we've come to the time
where hannah has to eliminate one person
and just a reminder hannah
one of these guys or all of them two of
them could be in it for the money oh my
god so pick wisely okay follow your
heart
you got this okay
um
yeah
i'm sorry emmanuel
bye hi it was a nice hug too you're a
good hugger thank you
congratulations guys you are moving on
to the last round
we can do one two yeah
you know what i think just gen z is a
little bit different
this is different
take a seat
i call this the love couch oh boy i'm
excited now
let's lounge together
hi
hello hi how are you hello i'm good we
meet again we do meet again
[Laughter]
you know what i feel like darren's the
type of dude to take you on a nice date
yeah i mean i'll get some oysters have a
good time you come back to this place
like let me get changed and he comes out
with like a turtleneck and some wine and
he sits back and i'm kind of like sure
you know what i mean
hi how you doing and you've been with
him all night i could just see him by a
fireplace
with a turtleneck on a [ __ ] fur
rug yeah yeah so if young you saw you
right now
like what would you think
cut your hair no way really i don't know
maybe you give off really good energy
okay i'm glad you as well you do as well
thank you
nice
yeah yeah nice
you don't make this better
yes
happy to be here
[Laughter]
[Music]
for this video bro
because that's the feeling i got inside
oh vehicle man the course on my own side
up
have you like tried to date around in
the past year is this my first time
meeting a stranger even in like 14
months oh my god i'm glad
you very very what what'd you say you
learned from your past relationships
trust now if you try to date other
people yeah no this is my first oh lucky
you cause me
you think she [ __ ] like the tasmanian
devil yeah
[Music]
i felt like i was gaslit a lot uh like
they try to make me feel crazy for like
saying certain things or doing certain
things i guess
so that's terrible yeah would you
benefit a lot from being in like a
serious relationship right now
do you feel that
i think well when i'm dating i kind of
date for happiness i'm not really the
type to date for like marriage or
anything but like if your happiness
turns into marriage eventually then
that's the good direction but right
that sounds like saying i'm a [ __ ] boy
with extra steps yes yes yes it sounds
like that counting with me of course
oh yeah well uh maybe we'll see you
maybe i'll see you i'm sure i'll see you
but uh we'll see ya
we'll see
that was a terrible hug yeah that was a
that was a touch hug yeah bruh this is
not uh yeah whatever you're good yeah
all right pro tip to everybody like yo
let your let your fingers dig in bring
it in close you don't have to go lead
with your pelvis but i think otherwise
you're coming
that's the only time i wanna hug is
creepy when you when you're like
you know
you don't make sound effects either it's
like i don't
know
no sound effects
i think i think i like them
hold it in there for a few seconds okay
too but you know what i found americans
are not good huggers yo americans yo
yeah
when i was you with you in the states
and i hugged this girl she said oh
you're a front hugger
[ __ ] is there any kind of other
americans hug like this hi
hugging like there's techniques boo boo
this is not muay thai this is not bjj
okay this is not mixed martial arts what
are you talking about front hug sidekick
low calf kick the [ __ ] is you talking
about
i didn't know hugs could trigger you my
[ __ ] no no but she said she said oh
you a front hugger yeah
is there any other kind yeah yeah side
hugger
hug different you know what i thought
when she said that frog like what do you
think of my back hugger that's creepy
oh come here girl
she said it she said you're a front
hugger i said as opposed to what i'm
back no you're thinking that you know
what i thought it was you come up from
the bishop
that's right [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but they hug from the side it's weird
i feel like that went really well i
think it did too those were some like
great conversations they flowed okay
sebastian i mean i feel like
like he's into me as much as i'm into
him
really getting to know each other i feel
like he he's sad every time time is up
yes yes
darren
body language was so relaxed like
comfortable with himself okay and i like
that okay but i don't know i don't know
why i have a little bit of a feeling
that he's in it for money
and not for the not for love do you have
that feeling with sebastian
no not at all i think it's actually the
opposite but hey i hope he's in it for
money yeah
his heart's on his sleeve he's in it for
love yes he wants you yes
hey guys
hello hi all right hannah the time has
come for you to choose who you want to
go on another date with just a reminder
they could be in it for the money but
they also could be in it for the love so
take your time what do you think
i think uh
surfer boys money there's only one
that's for information there might be
multiple i think they both for the money
okay i think darren's for love lead with
your heart
who are you choosing
um
i just like like lounging on the couch
with both of you seeing how you lounge
was nice
well
i choose
sebastian
would you go on a date with me i would
love to
okay
can we hug
okay guys this is the final round this
show is all about seeing past the
surfaces and trying to get to someone's
true intentions do you think you did
that today hannah yes do you think you
made the right choice i think so
love our money
money
i picked him for money time to reveal
what you chose
[Music]
i'm just in it why for the happiness
what makes me happy
is getting some money
so you can kiki key and laugh all the
way there and you know what damon's
going to go home knowing that you didn't
choose him goodbye [ __ ] and i betcha we
did it for the love
calm down jesus christ i know i got so
excited you got it i feel like all those
ladies will watch the season finale of
bachelorette you know what i'm saying
can i channel my bachelorette fan energy
you're a bad [ __ ]
now
[Music]
i didn't see that coming i didn't feel
like going i'm the bad guy but i mean
good for you congratulations well i
can't have you here any longer you can't
get her number you can't get her socials
you have to leave without even saying
bye really yeah all right well it's been
fun
god damn i can't say bye okay
good for you man
hannah
wow what did darren say though
we're about to find out oh wow
what
like
i'm
speechless the same
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that smile he didn't smile once
like that when he was with her and now
you're seeing the face of his happiness
she
do i feel bad for her of course not
you got a little bit caught up like
usher okay and you what you got burnt
all right and i'm not even talking about
let it burn i'm talking about chlamydia
didn't he have chlamydia no it was
herpes
that's an even worse burn technically
[Music]
i feel evil yeah what i tell you yeah
you know
darren if you ever need a drink i'll get
you one all right you can't show up in a
turtleneck nor will i ever go anywhere
with a fireplace with you but if you
want to drink i got you
did you enjoy the conversations with
hannah she's great yeah i mean i feel
bad for my choice even if it wasn't for
money would you have taken hannah on a
date i would have loved to yeah she's
fun she's cute i mean
i'm traveling like all next year so it
just didn't really make sense for me to
like get into a committed relationship
right now and now you can pay for your
travels exactly exactly hey man this
man's got his fuckboy speech down pat
it's like hey girl i'm not here for a
long time just a good time
that's what he just said happiness
he's there for his penis
it's not happiness it's a penis he's
there for a
we got it we get it
you guys can rate his [ __ ] little
thing there out of ten they're not his
penis this joke whatever how do you feel
i feel
beyond shook i'm shook once
scared to look scared to death they
shook cause ain't no such thing as
halfway crooks man whatever that [ __ ]
plays
all i do is imagine the brooklyn bridge
and robin [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know when i start
yeah
this is one of the songs that we're
banning much y'all some of my munchau
clubs yeah you can play that [ __ ] you
can play that [ __ ] that because you know
the sound right no no let me play the
stop yo
yeah
so we're really in the hundred dollar
bills
[Applause]
you can't you can't no no no you there's
some songs that's that that song that's
some songs that i don't know man no
there's some songs i don't know how the
way it hits you they did that [ __ ] they
did that [ __ ] with voodoo yes because he
you know
yeah
you know i mean yeah man man listen no
but she was talking about
i have no doubt that you're gonna find
somebody for you you know i mean if
you're ever on tinder and you see the
name roadrunner definitely hit them up
um but otherwise i thought this was a
fun video i enjoyed this it was funny it
was good that was good you know darren
you know what i mean you're a sweet dude
keep your head up and keep making your
silicone valley money that's it anything
else nah man
that [ __ ] was alright
[Music]
[Applause]
that's why you guys can't see my hair
today i got my fuckboy haircut and i'm
just trying to hide it because i'm still
trying to be undercover that's a lie you
just snapping that [ __ ] on the side
nah you know what it is what is it i've
been like watching like um i watched i
watched baby boy you just a baby boy
and you just feel like you need a drag
you
[Music]
yo
that soundtrack was dope fantastic
it was dope when tyreese still had his
life together yeah yeah not crying about
fast and furious machines exactly yo
tyrese was still respecting yo yeah
yo i was playing like sweet lady yeah i
just started like sliding my due rack on
the way i was gonna slide in some
drawers later what i mean i gotta keep
my rag on yo listen that's a great song
all the young people are like what's
baby boy yo yeah exactly what's this
sweet lady when snoop dogg was a ghost
tyrese lady this was an r b was still r
b okay go enjoy it and baby boy snoop
dogg
was the skinniest villain i've seen in
my life and he was yeah yeah he's way
more respectable than two
it wasn't wasn't yet but anyways let's
play